[Musique]
elle s'appelle Bénédicte elle a 23 ans
elle attend cet instant depuis 9 heures
du matin
le phénomène n'est pas nouveau et comme
tout phénomène il correspond à une
époque bien déterminée mesdemoiselles au
risque de vous décevoir Patrick Bruel
n'est pas unique en son genre avant lui
Elvis Presley Frank Sinatra les Beatles
Claude François et j'en passe tous on
déchaîné les foules ce qu'on appelle les
femmes mais le public de Patrick Bruel
est essentiellement féminin et il est
vrai qu'à chaque concert il déclenche
l'hystérie de celle qui le considère
comme un ami ou un grand frère Lorraine
de Bézieux et Philippe montoisy se sont
penchés sur le cabruel ils ont suivi
quelques jeunes filles éperdument
amoureuses de leur idole ils ont
interrogé aussi quelque part en inquiets
par les proportions que commençaient à
prendre le phénomène voici leur
reportage portrait de la génération
Bruelle une génération plutôt saine et
sympathique et qui n'hésitent pas à se
casser la voix
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle s'appelle Bénédicte elle a 23 ans
elle attend cet instant depuis 9 heures
du matin
le lendemain du concert Bénédicte moi
fébrile retrouve son univers quotidien
elle est podologue dans un cabinet de la
région parisienne depuis un an
c'est aussi depuis un an que Patrick
comme elle l'appelle toute est entrée
dans sa vie de jeune femme active pour
mieux prolonger ses rêves d'adolescence
j'attends de
peut-être de devenir une amie avec lui
mais
te devenir une amie une amie simplement
quoi qu'on irait boire un coup d'aller
au cinéma ou
mais c'est sûr que dans mes rêves mais
je peux pas aussi dire
j'attends plus de choses de Patrick
parce que je sais qu'au fond moi-même
c'est pas possible c'est pas réalisable
c'est vrai que je pourrais dire
j'attends de Patrick de couche avec
j'attends d'avoir un enfant de Bruel
mais
à moins que lui dise ah bah c'est
peut-être la bonne j'en sais rien
mais c'est vrai que
au fond de moi-même j'ai ce côté
réaliste qui disent le côté pied sur
terre qui me dit ma pauvre fille t'as
aucune chance avec Bruel mais c'est vrai
que dans mes rêves quand je suis dans
une ambiance concerne je cache pas de
dire ouais je ferais n'importe quoi pour
faire un enfant à Bruel
[Musique]
j'ai réussi sauf quand il aime
la persévrine me regarde pas Christelle
17 ans est en classe de première au
lycée d'Argenteuil dans la banlieue nord
de Paris
à chaque fan sa façon d'aimer elle elle
compte les jours passer avec son idole
cela fait un an et 7 mois que Christelle
le suit pas à pas marche dans ses mots
pas un album pas un journal ne lui
échappe on connaît juste une image de
lui je voudrais reconnaître vraiment
ce qu'il pense si c'est vrai tout ce qui
dit quoi je voudrais savoir si c'est
vrai
parler
puis plein d'autres choses et surtout
parler et correspond à ton idéal
l'image que j'ai lu oui
après je sais pas quelle image tu es
[Musique]
il sait ce qu'il veut
et puis pour le peu qu'il fait voir il a
l'air tendre je le considère en fait
comme un grand frère pas comme un petit
ami c'est vraiment il donne des exemples
c'est comme un grand frère
[Applaudissements]
pour Dominique 16 ans Bruel représente
bien plus qu'un grand frère
comme tous les jours Dominique et ses
copines de concert sèchent les cours
pour se rendre au domicile de la star
elles sont prêtes à tout pour
l'entrevoir quelques secondes même si
chaque fois elles sont déçues
les grands rendez-vous d'amour qui leur
donnent sur scène ne leur suffisait plus
Dominique Aurélie Cathy et Mélanie n'ont
plus qu'une obsession lui déclarait
ouvertement leur flamme
en fait jamais tirer voir Patrick et lui
dire
pire que ça
fait Patrick je t'aime
rigoler vêtements
et bah oui bah tu crois que je vais pas
tarder
le concert comment c'était trop bien tu
sais quoi j'ai encore pleuré
quand il fait personne personne j'ai eu
besoin de personne obligé
regarde
à chaque fois je suis là il fait passer
des messages à ses chansons c'est sûr
je sais pas
il nous dit il fait pas ça fait pas
cette connerie là faites ça écoutez pas
ces gens-là
faites gaffe quoi en fait il me fait
ouvrir un peu les yeux enfin j'ouvre les
yeux quoi sur le monde qui nous entoure
surtout et on comprend dans ces textes
il ouais il nous dirige vers les bonnes
directions
si tu fais gaffe quoi accrochez-vous et
quand je vois que j'ai plus en pot je me
dis merde quelque chose que j'arrive pas
j'arrive pas
c'est vrai que
il peut faire changer des gens qui
prennent pas les bons chemins c'est pas
les bonnes décisions qui
lui dit qu'il est pas un porte-parole je
suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec lui
en fait parce qu'il me dirige il me
dirige vers les chemins à prendre et il
veut pas se faire passer pour un truc de
parole mais en fait c'est ce qu'il est
réussie tu fais médecin de la sixième à
la terminale voici la génération Bruelle
pour ces mômes qui ont peur de l'avenir
peur de la solitude pour elle c'est un
peu d'espoir dans un monde difficile les
lycéens moi je les perçois un peu cette
génération comme des gens qui ont envie
d'action collective
qui ont une certaine envie de solidarité
mais un peu limitée sans forcément
remettre en cause de façon radicale le
système et moi il me semble que Bruel
correspond un petit peu à cette valeur
là
une certaine solidarité
limitée
sans remettre en cause le fonctionnement
de la société
puis à ça tombe de valeur de tolérance
que que les élèves sont habitués à
pratiquer au lycée de la tolérance il en
faut beaucoup à l'entourage de ces fans
pour supporter tous les jours cette
Bruelle Mania le petit ami de Christelle
lui a bien résisté
et toi GG au début
elle m'a expliqué quand ça lui a pris
j'ai vu tout ce qu'elle avait sur lui
j'ai écouté toutes ces musiques
je connaissais pas toutes mais bon
maintenant on en parle moins maintenant
et comment tu le vis toi
c'est
j'ai l'impression qu'il fait partie pas
de la famille mais mon entourage
j'ai l'impression que je le connais mais
pas je le connais comme personnellement
c'est un peu comme si j'avais déjà parlé
avec lui
comment tu le vis
ça ne me dérange pas
je suis pas là Dominique elle n'a même
plus de petit ami elle a éliminé de sa
vie tout ce qui pouvait entraver son
intimité avec Patrick son idole plus de
relation en dehors du fan club plus
d'école au grand désespoir de sa mère
qui préfèrent témoigner dans l'ombre
pour éviter une rupture définitive avec
sa fille
au début c'était une simple
une simple admiration pour un chanteur
jeune qui s'adresse aux jeunes avec des
paroles de jeunes et peu à peu ma fille
est tombée sous son emprise à savoir
qu'elle a voulu rentrer en contact plus
direct avec l'homme privé l'homme
Patrick Bruel elle a réussi par je ne
sais quel moyen à se procurer sans son
adresse elle y est allée elle est la
réussite effectivement à rencontrer en
contact avec lui et à partir de là elle
n'a plus vécu que pour lui que pour ses
chansons elle a eu une seule une seule
idée c'est de passer ses journées devant
chez lui à savoir ce qu'il faisait à
quelle heure où il allait quand il
sortait quand il rentrait à pouvoir lui
parler le jour où chaque combattant
détruite ça s'arrêter voilà ce sera lui
qui fera quelque chose que ça
que tout ce que tout se peut en moi mais
ce jour-là je sais pas quand est-ce
qu'il arrivera qu'est-ce qu'il veut te
faire décrocher qu'est-ce qui peut me
faire décrocher le jouet se mariera ou
alors le jour où il va où il réussir
enfin avoir un enfant
je serais heureuse pour lui mais là
c'est tout stop
ce sera la cassure
tu sais que ça va arriver parce que bon
on a 32 ans on va bien falloir qu'il
s'occupe un petit peu lui qui font une
famille mais
à ce jour-là ce sera sera la catastrophe
qu'est-ce que tu feras tu sais pas je
pleure à toute la journée toute la
semaine et je sais pas ce que je ferais
j'aurais plus aucun réflexe je sais pas
je sais pas du tout ce que ce que je
ferais
je préfère même pas y penser je préfère
même pas penser que ce jour va arriver
je veux pas
je veux rien savoir
[Applaudissements]
et les chevaux qui tiennent comme je
traîne en ennui la maquille la vie quand
je me réveille
[Musique]